While Gradle provides a great model for
projects, allowing you to define
tasks and dependencies between them,
by default an empty build script
doesn't do much, or anything really.
This is on by design.
Gradle doesn't want to enforce any
opinions on how your build should work.
In fact, your Gradle build doesn't
necessarily have to build anything.
Fundamentally, Gradle
is an automation tool.
So, whether it's an Android project,
Java project, C/C++ project, or
database migration build, Gradle is
there to make cumbersome tasks easy.
However, in many cases our projects
will follow some conventions.
And those conventions carry over
into how we build our project.
We want to provide some way to
tell Gradle, what kind of project
we're building, and what capabilities
we want as part of our build.
Just like a big software project
is easy to understand when it's
broken up into highly
cohesive libraries,
it also makes sense to factor out
build logic into reusable components.
With Gradle we do this
through the use of plugins.
A good plugin extends the Gradle
model to encompass some new domain.
Providing new tasks,
new DSL elements to configure, and
sensible default behaviors.
A plugin can do anything that can be
done in a Gradle build script itself.
They can define tasks,
configure repositories, or
even apply other plugins.
Plugins can even extend the Gradle DSL,
allowing users to model
a specific domain.
Later on in this course,
we'll learn how the Google Android
team has done exactly this, to allow
developers to describe their Android
projects in Gradle build scripts.
Next, let's learn where we can find
out more about the hundreds of
Gradle plugins that
are freely available.